what up space fam goals in here for
anime uproar and today we are going to
be talking about the sometimes cowardly
but always legendary lightning avatar
himself is any - he gets scared like
cool sob he hits on girls like Sanji and
he kicks butt with his epic
swordsmanship skills like Zorro he's one
of my favorite characters and demon
slayer and I'm really looking forward to
taking a closer look at him in this
video after all
he's had some of the best character
development in the entire series if you
want to see more demon slayer character
breakdowns smash that like button to let
me know and leave suggestions for future
videos in the comments if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell so you actually get
notified when you'd even say our vids
drop for more Demon Slayer content and
crucial updates follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar lastly there
will be manga spoilers in this video
you've been warned now without further
ado let's jump into it although he is
one of only four people who make it
through the Demon Slayer exam sunny sue
comes off like a weak coward initially
rather than celebrating making it
through or mourning the death of others
saying - focuses immediately on how he
will die along with the others who
passed for him it's only a matter of
time
furthermore instead of a crow sunny -
gets a tiny sparrow this further singles
him out as weaker and less intimidating
than the others later Tundra walks into
him again and xeni - is tried to get a
girl to marry him but she's not having
it all those limits who can act cowardly
he has a lot of confidence when it comes
to hitting on girls
and he even assumes that girls like him
even when they clearly don't after the
girl leaves and ton zero space makes the
most pitiful expression at designing sue
that you can imagine is that who starts
to cry and tells time to know that he's
about to die he says he's super weak and
that he needs time to know to protect
him as tonzura points out is any - is
completely shameless in other words he
is the complete opposite of Eskin or
hashtag praise the Sun science reveals
that he became a swordsman because he
was deceived by a woman and got into a
bunch of debt the guy's a nice who owes
money to made him repaid that the woman
owes him by grooming Zanna sue he put
him through hellish training every day
and that into thought he might as well
but he didn't he made it to the final
selection exam where he thought he would
also die but he did it now though it
seems like this swordsmanship lifestyle
is really going to kill him in other
words any two came into this lifestyle
kicking and screaming it wasn't his own
choice like it was tangelos this is
actually refreshing and it makes what
happens later on in the story all the
more meaningful the mangaka koi Haru
Gotoh game does a great job of setting
up Zanna to his character so far he
seems like a complete coward with
absolutely no redeemable qualities he's
always complaining he asks others to
save him he ignores his missions to hit
on girls and so on a little later when
tundra faces kyogen they lose even more
scared than the people he is supposed to
be protecting he's a crybaby and he has
more fear than anyone and that is
exactly why the scene where's Eddie to
protect sneza Coast box from an auskey
is so freakin powerful even though he
knew that tundra carried a demon in
there from the beginning is any too well
protected because he knows that it is
tangelos most precious possession
besides who has super hearing powers and
if he listens closely enough he is even
able to know what a person is thinking
about he can tell from the gentle sound
that comes from Tangier oh that he can
be trusted and that he has a good reason
for keeping a demon in the box he knows
he calls him a coward who's too afraid
to pull his blade but in truth was
ending to his taking damage to protect
the box the entire time he could have
left he could have ran away and handed
over the box but he chose to stay
despite the fact that he is such a fear
filled person he took hit after hit
because he prioritized tangelos wishes
to his own well-being that would
normally be very admirable on its own
but the effects are amplified because of
Sciences cowardly personality it's been
said that courage is not the absence of
fear rather courage is acting in the
face of fear thus the more fear you face
the more courageous you are and ZENIT's
who probably faced more fear than anyone
else would in that situation so setting
to a simultaneously the most cowardly
and the most courageous in a sense
that's our first hint that there's
something really special about xeni -
actions speak louder than words and
despite what he says about himself when
the chips are down he steps up and is
willing to put his life on the line
friend when he figures out that Tom judo
is keeping a girl as cute as medical in
the box
he is extremely angry and jealous at
first but when he learns that it's tons
of a sister he pretty much becomes set
on marrying a Zuko arguably the cutest
girl in anime and in truth I Chapelle
let me know if you ship it or skip it in
the comments the next significant moment
where's any to literally shines is when
the group has to fight the spider demon
family decided to is justifiably
freaking out when he comes into contact
with a creepy spider demon and he
realizes that he's been infected with
the venom and is in the process of
becoming a spider regular spiders are
creepy let alone this nightmarish
scenario at this point we get access to
some important backstory details about
zenit soon we get to see black hairs on
it soon as freaked out as ever and his
son say as he hinted at earlier on he
was saved from the woman that got him
into debt by his sensei so you might
think that you should pay a sensei back
by being a good student but no he's
hiding in a tree begging not to go on
with the training
well his sensei is trying to get him to
calm down not necessarily what you think
of when you think of demon slayer
material his sense is very nice though
and he is flattered and can't say angry
when zayats who says he loves him thanks
who wants to live up to his sensei's
expectations but he experiences a lot of
resistance he thinks he can't do it even
though his sensei is supportive and
assurance on it sooo that he has the
talent that's when lightning hits the
tree and sightings who gets a permanent
blonde hairstyle which to be honest
suits him way better
while this flashback is taking place say
sue is again hiding in a tree in the
spider forest he says he didn't like
himself the most he always thought he
had to do everything properly but he was
afraid and would run and cry he wants to
change he wants to become a proper human
being he cries and says he's doing his
best
at this point Senate Suh has hit rock
bottom he feels completely powerless and
helpless I think to an extent we can all
relate to how he feels maybe we don't
need to worry about turning into a giant
spider well we've all been there where
we've been scared and felt like
something was too much for us to handle
I've definitely been there myself and I
think to an extent it's something we all
have to face that is why we root so much
for as any - because we see a part of
ourselves in him
we also have these inner conflicts even
if we don't climb a tree and cry every
time in his book the war of art Steven
Pressfield calls this resistance by the
way I strongly recommend this book to
everyone Pressfield talks about
self-loathing that voice in our heads
that says you're a loser you're a bum a
worthless waste of oxygen look at you
you believe that someone like you could
accomplish or do anything meaningful
Pressfield labels this voice the voice
of resistance and I need to experiences
it just as we do resistance is defined
by Pressfield as an impartial force of
nature like gravity resistance is clever
it knows if it personalizes its
manifestations it can deceive us and
slip past our defenses and quote
resistance is not personal we all
experience that voice of self-loathing
sometimes however believe it or not this
is good we experience resistance when
we're trying to step up in life and do
something meaningful like finally write
that essay or create that video or kill
that demon spider when we are trying to
step up in life and doing so would be
significant for our own development as
human beings that is one resistance
shows up so resistance can be a compass
it's telling you what you should do in
Sciences case he's feeling so much
resistance because a part of him knows
that he needs to step up to his demon
enemies he needs to step up to his fear
he's not at the point where he can just
do it consciously right away but he will
be there eventually and it is this
gradual overcoming of resistance that
makes any transformation over the series
so impactful in the spider force he does
face resistance although he seems to
feint first as the series goes on though
he becomes better and better at facing
resistance consciously the more time he
does it the fight against the demon
spider is great because the spider was
so confident his abilities he thought
that Zen ISA would be the easiest of
prey however is any - even though he can
only use the first breath of thunder
form ends up absolutely destroying the
spider his sensei taught him to turn his
weaknesses into a strength
he told Zhang - if you can only use one
form he should use it as much as he can
he should work on it until it's reached
the limit of the limit this is great
advice for life the businessman Gary
Vaynerchuk often says that people need
to double and triple down on what
they're good at rather than focusing too
much
I'm on their weaknesses for instance I
make youtube videos and a lot of you out
there enjoy them but I can't fix a
fridge or a toilet
Shh cry about this and spend months
trying to learn how to do this stuff and
spend less time on YouTube videos
absolutely not
I accept that I can't fix a fridge or
that a plumber knows more than me about
my toilet I can pay someone else to do
those things my time is better spent on
creating more content for you and
growing this channel it is this kind of
single-minded focus that leads to
meaningful and even explosive results
and we see just how much it paid off for
zenny to during one of the most epic
moments in the entire anime so far even
though sunny - has a million reasons to
give up like that he's scared he's
poisoned his limbs are going numb his
movements are getting weaker the pain
continues to grow and he's about to
throw up he can't help but think about
it sensei and how his sensei never gave
up on him while everyone else in his
life did people insulted him said he was
useless and unwanted but his sensei
believed in him
although sunny - never dreamed of a
future where he could seize and
accomplish something or be useful to
someone or be able to protect someone to
the very end his sensei never gave up on
him he ran away again and again and his
sensei would pull him back again and
again
thus he refuses to let down his sensei's
expectations for him he uses his refined
breath of thunder first form
thunderclap flash and slices the spider
demons head off before he even knew what
hit him thanks to a sensei as any too
now has a dream a happy dream when he's
strong stronger than anyone else where
he can help the weak and trouble people
anytime it's nice to realize that his
time with his sensei wasn't wasted on
him it wasn't useless he got stronger
thanks to his sensei and he got a dream
that he can work towards a dream where
he can be useful to others he overcame
resistance in this moment and it was
glorious as his sensei said it may hurt
and it may be difficult but don't give
up - comfort and quote overcoming
resistance can be a very uncomfortable
process but it is always worth it in the
end the last significant moment I want
to go over is that he to fight with his
former sent by Kai gaku they both
trained under the same Sun sight
together
kai gaku never got along with xeni - he
hated Zazu buds
- despite hating him back still
respected him because he worked hard and
he was driven yet Kai Goku couldn't
learn the first form walls any two could
only learn the first one Kakaako was
upset that he worked so hard in his
sensei never gave him the successor
title he wanted him to share the
successorship with Zenit SU so Kai Goku
became a demon and when he did there
Sensei committed ritual suicide just
like GU and sukwon G promised to do if
Nezha ko kills a human except in the
Thunder sensei's case no one was there
to behead him after he slit his stomach
as a result rather than a quick death he
suffered a long and agonizing one not
only does Kai gaku not feel sorry for
being the cause of his sensei's death
and suffering he's even relieved that he
killed himself because his former sensei
didn't recognize how great I got was
during this battles angels act scared at
all and he doesn't need to go
unconscious or faint in order to fight
he is so committed to avenging his
sensei the only person who believed in
him and gave him hope that he has no
room for fear not only has any to caught
up to Kai Goku even with his demon
power-ups he even surpasses him he has
even created a new seventh form of
Thunder style called flaming Thunder God
and he used it to finish Kai Goku and
upper Moon off by himself now yes kai
gaku didn't have much time to get used
to his new demon powers but the fact
remains that zeni - who was scared of
his own shadow at the beginning of the
story just be one of the strongest
demons without showing any fear it is a
complete transformation and to all of us
who are rooting for this underdog since
the beginning this moment of triumph is
extremely satisfying in a way it's sad
how kagaku turned out since then it's to
always hope to fight alongside him but
Kai Goku was too arrogant and couldn't
accept being on equal terms with Zenit
sooo ironically
not only was he not stronger than Sonny
- he's arguably weaker yet ZENIT's who
never once felt or acted like he was
superior
ushiro even tells Kai Goku as he's dying
and I quote those who don't give to
others will never receive anything back
from them just like those who only
desire will end up with nothing in the
end because you can't create anything
dying alone sure is pathetic and quote
then you [ __ ] all goes to help send it
soon as we knows that means to spend his
life
trying to help people his dream is to
protect others he protected tangelos box
and took a huge beating because of it he
wanted to live up to the expectations of
a sensei and make him proud thus while
kagaku who lived a completely selfish
self-centered life dies it's no surprise
that sunny to get saved you can call it
karma justice or whatever you want but
it's true that when you help and give to
others others will help and give to you
in turn as a perfect way to finish off
Saints whose character arc up to this
point does any - gets a glimpse of his
sensei in the afterlife settings who
begins apologizing for not helping him
with kagaku he blames himself for
everything that happened to his sensei
his sensei's eyes water up just like Zen
etudes and he tells any - that he's his
pride and joy then saint who comes back
to consciousness he's made his sensei
proud just as he's always wanted to do
he overcame his fear and resistance and
consciously defeat in a demon moon by
himself by doing so there's no telling
how many thousands of innocent lives
he's saved the sun-eater's definitely
come a long way from the cowering and
powerless person he seemed to be in the
beginning I think we can all learn from
Sanctus example figure out what your
dream is work towards it patiently and
overcome the fear and resistance that
will inevitably come up during the
journey Zhang's whose journey is not
done yet but I think we can all agree
that he's already glad he chose to step
up and get closer to his dream rather
than run away and seek comfort instead
so that was thanks to his motivational
story up to this point now let's take a
look at his unique powers I mentioned
some of his powers already but I'll
outline them in more detail here as we
knows I need to use the breath of
thunder style sometimes translated as
breath of lightning this technique
allows any two to reach superhuman
levels of speed and strength there are
six official forms within the style but
because he was so untalented sending to
could only initially learn the first one
which is considered to be the simplest
however he perfected this first form to
such a degree that it far surpasses that
of other Thunder style users he's like
The Rock Lee of Thunder style and the
first form is his taijutsu nevertheless
Zen eats who does eventually learn a new
form and not only that is a form that he
created he calls it the seventh warm
flaming Thunder God he can also use God
speed twice a day which
makes us already fast techniques way
faster but after the second time his
legs will be practically useless he can
multiply the effectiveness of the first
form thundercloud flash he seemingly
multiplies its power and speed against
Docky
he showed that he can at least multiply
its effectiveness by a factor of eight
then there's his original seventh form
flaming thunder god that allows him to
travel like lightning through the air in
a specific direction he uses this
ability to quickly travel up to chi gong
coos location in the air and cut off his
head before he can react it's clear that
this technique is extremely fast since a
skilled and demon enhanced thunder
breath user couldn't even stop it it's
also powerful as we seen the manga
lightning esque energy seems to come off
sights his body in large quantities and
it takes a shape of a large dragon it's
definitely one of my favorite forms that
we've seen so far and by using it Saints
who proves that there is more than one
way to skin a traitorous Empire in
addition to these abilities settings who
has enhanced hearing he can hear the
inner thoughts of people by using his
hearing to the fullest and he can use it
to locate demons since they produce a
different sound than humans enhanced
hearing allows him to react quickly in
any combat situation even if his eyes
are closed it's fitting that he has
enhanced hearing since thunder is
associated with sound as well then
there's any choose unconscious avatar
like state earlier on if he gets too
scared he passes out and yet starts
kicking but instinct takes over and as a
result he is no longer hindered by his
conscious fears and doubts however as we
saw earlier on in this video this was a
crutch that he eventually stops relying
on now with new and improved skills and
courage he can fight at his best while
maintaining consciousness as we saw when
he fought Chi gaku and that is it for
today's video you can always see more
about Zen e - but I think I covered a
good amount in this video and hopefully
I helped you see why he's one of my
favorite characters if I miss something
you really want to talk about you can
leave it in the comments below is that
it is a constant reminder of what's
possible if we are willing to face our
fears and overcome resistance in our own
lives I hope his story inspires you as
much as it inspires me if you did enjoy
this video make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bells you actually get
notified when new demon slayer videos
come out let me know who you would like
to see explained next for even more
Demon Slayer content and crucial updates
you can follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar a big thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who help make videos like this one
possible I especially want to thank our
pro hero to your patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing about a fan Jason
Wilson King zelgius angel Cruz Steelers
poet Pablo and a Tropos rape and are the
one tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and radha aloha on
item matty mac 239 and makoto-kun if you
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon common app
for and becoming a patron today for as
little as one dollar if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these pillars right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]